tenemos la ecuación 7 menos 10 sobre x
igual a 215 sobre x ésta no es una
ecuación de las que estás acostumbrado a
resolver pero te doy un momento para que
consideres si la podría resolver solo
veremos que al hacer una multiplicación
a ambos lados la podemos simplificar y
llevarla a una forma de las que estás
acostumbrado a hacer lo que
probablemente te está molestando a mí si
me está molestando son estas equis que
tenemos aquí como denominadores como
manejamos eso como tenemos una equis en
el denominador lo que se ocurre es
multiplicar por equis pero no podemos
multiplicar tan solo un término por
equis tenemos que multiplicar por equis
todo el lado izquierdo así es que
multiplicamos este lado por equis pero
no puedo multiplicar tan solo un lado
por x tenemos que multiplicar el lado
derecho también por equis y que nos
resulta bien distribuimos la equis del
lado izquierdo
aquí tenemos 7 x y x x menos 10 sobre x
es simplemente menos 10 menos 10 así es
que el lado izquierdo nos queda 7 x
menos 10 y esto es igual a de nueva
cuenta distribuimos la x x por 2 es
igual a 2x y luego x por 15 entre x x
por 15 3 x 4 tienes x x algo
/ algo te va a dar ese algo en si es que
en este caso esto es 15 y ya le hemos
simplificado con una ecuación lineal
donde tenemos la variable a ambos lados
de la igualdad simplemente tenemos que
aplicar las técnicas que ya conocemos
vamos a llevar entonces las x del lado
izquierdo y para eso lo que se me ocurre
aquí es eliminar este 2x prestando menos
2x pero te recuerdo que no puedes hacer
algo de un solo lado porque perdería la
igualdad hay que hacerlo a ambos lados
de la ecuación
así es que menos 2x también lo tenemos
que restar del lado izquierdo y esto que
nos da del lado izquierdo nos queda voy
a hacerlo nuevamente en rosa nos queda 7
x menos 2 x esto es igual a 5 x menos 10
y del lado derecho tenemos 2 x menos 2 x
se cancelan en lo que queríamos y sólo
nos queda 15 ahora podemos eliminar este
10 sumando 10
prefiero el verde cuando hago cosas a
ambos lados así es que sumamos 10 del
lado izquierdo y sumamos 10 del lado
derecho y que nos resulta entonces 5 x
10 10 se cancelan y del lado derecho
queda 15 10 es igual a 25 y ahora para
despejar esta x dividimos entre 5 ambos
lados y me queda del lado izquierdo me
queda x del lado derecho me queda 5 las
soluciones x igual a 5 verifiquemos que
la solución es correcta
vayamos a la ecuación original tenemos 7
menos 10 sobre 5 ya estoy sustituyendo
el valor de x igual a 5 en la ecuación
esto es igual a 2 más 15 sobre 5 así del
lado izquierdo es 7 menos 10 sobre 5 es
2 nos queda 7 menos 2 y del lado derecho
tenemos 2 más 15 sobre 5 que es igual a
3 que da dos más tres del lado izquierdo
de 72 que es igual a 5 2 más 3 es igual
a 55 es igual a 5 así es que nuestra
solución es correcta hemos terminado